un beau cadeau d'anniversaire pour le
coach Michael est qui fait te tiercé 48
ans vous allez le voir dans les
coulisses de la diabloie la Diablo qui a
battu hier l'asvelle à la salle du Jeu
de Paume score final à 86 à 82 un
deuxième succès pour le premier bléois
face au mastodonte villeurbannees
champion de France en titre retour sur
les meilleurs moments de ce match avec
Florent
[Applaudissements]
clavelles
communion intense hier soir quelques
secondes après le coup de sifflet final
entre la D à Blois et son public dans un
jeu de paume plein à craquer les
blaiseaux en fait plus que remplir leur
contrat
première victoire à domicile en Betclic
élite contre le champion de France en
titre et avec la manière
dans les travées d'ailleurs juste avant
le coup d'envoi les supporteurs ne s'y
était pas trompés par ayant sur un Adea
des grands soirs vous êtes heureux de
voir que notre équipe elle a progressé
qu'elle a plutôt compliqué et on espère
attendre la victoire pour ce soir ça va
être le feu qui s'est fermé comme ça ça
va être le feu là le feu dans les
tribunes est dans les jambes le suspense
pour combustible dès les premières
minutes villeurbanais et Blaise doit se
rendre coup pour coup
mais cornéli est là trois points au
buzzer
[Musique]
la bascule est faite 20 19 à la fin du
premier carton dès lors la Déa fera la
course en tête parce que les Blésois
peuvent être heureux et nous aussi on
est fiers de porter nos couleurs et de
voilà de montrer un petit message quoi
de dire bon bah cette année on va être
là quoi prenez nous au sérieux après un
mano à manoaltant les promus passent à
l'attaque après la pause cornéli
meilleur marqueur Blaise du match avec
16 points mais aussi vergers et gagitch
13 points tous les deux permettent aux
locaux de mener nettement à la fin du
troisième carton 70 58 la suite est
suffocante les villeurbanais recollant à
deux points 82 80 à moins de 1 minute
trente du buzzer mais les blesses
tiennent bon vous n'aurez pu être un peu
plus devant mais on perd des ballons un
petit peu à la con du manque de notre
maîtrise technique mais après on met
aussi des shooter on sentait que c'était
une soirée pour nous il faut avancer et
je pense même qu'à la fin du match on
peut même tuer le match avant parce
qu'on a des choses ouvertes une nouvelle
fois l'abnégation de tout le monde
toutes les équipes embethli que j'ai
depuis le début il faut les respecter et
il faut aider le début sinon après les
matchs seront toujours compliqués score
final 86 82 2 matchs de victoire pour
les Blaise en Belgique élite la Diablo a
écrit son histoire sans complexe